Welcome back to "late night."
We're here with Jordan Klepper.
You went to Hungary,
and Hungary has been
turning up in the discourse here
a bit more,
certainly amongst conservatives.
What is the draw of Hungary?
Why do we see Tucker Carlson
go there and speak from Hungary?
-That was the question
we were trying to answer
when we went there.
I think, quite honestly,
they have a leader,
Viktor Orban,
who has been called
a "more competent" Trump.
Steve Bannon called him
"Trump before Trump."
And he's sort of created
this conservative wonderland
over there.
He's been in power for 12 years,
something I think
Trump would love to do.
-Mm-hmm.
-He's used wedge issues
to get people on board.
Right now
the LGBTQ issues are something
he's codified
in the constitution,
taking away rights
from that community.
He's starting to equate
homosexuality to pedophilia.
He's creating sort of a scare
over there
that's getting people
out to the polls.
And what you start
to see is, like,
nationalism is starting to reign
in Hungary,
and I think conservatives
in America look over there
and they see somebody
who has the power they want,
is perhaps a smarter version
of the man they had in charge,
and is able to put people
in power in that country
so that it's much harder
for them to get out of power.
So it sort of looks like
what I think conservatives
might think America
could look like in a few years.
-And are there similarities
between what you see there --
It certainly seemed, maybe
a little bit more in the clip,
a little bit more polite,
a little bit more controlled?
But are there similarities
with a MAGA rally?
-Some, yes. I mean,
I went to the merch table.
And sort of, like, if you don't
have a Second Amendment,
what do you put
on your T-shirts?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Calvin can't piss on CNN
over here, so what --
what is the political
discourse, guys?
-Yeah.
-There's definite similarities.
You know, the rhetoric --
Quite honestly,
they go to Soros as a bad guy,
who is from Hungary.
And, in fact, some of these
tactics were stolen by America
to make the boogeyman
that Hungary already had.
I was shocked at how many people
referenced Joe Biden
and specifically talked about
Hunter Biden's laptop
in Budapest.
Like, I'm going over there
talking about
the war in Ukraine,
which is literally
next to Hungary.
Which -- I know geography.
I've known where Hungary is
for literally months now.
That's where it is.
-Yeah.
-So they have a war next door,
but still
this obfuscation of reality
and the focus on things
like Hunter Biden's laptop,
that's out there
in the streets of Budapest,
and people are ready
to engage with me about it.
-So, you're doing a podcast
right now with John Kasich.
John Kasich,
former governor of Ohio.
-It's what the people
asked for.
-That's what they asked for.
And he's been on this show,
and I always thought,
"You know who you'd love?
Klepper."
-"You guys got to do
a thing together!"
-So, how did this happen?
Because this does not seem
like a natural pairing.
-You know, it's a governor
meet cute that I think --
Things got weird
during the pandemic.
-Sure.
-You know, we were all looking
for connection in strange ways.
We all dabbled
with our own governors.
We know. We went through this.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's not weird.
It's natural, you know?
So you find a governor
in a midsize state,
and you start to meet over Zoom.
And some folks
actually said, like,
"Hey, Governor Kasich
is looking to do a podcast
and talk to somebody
with a different point of view.
I think you guys
would hit it off."
And I wasn't super into
doing a political podcast.
And as soon as we got on a Zoom
together, I was shocked
because we talked about
Rage Against the Machine
for most of the time.
-Yeah.
-He's a huge music fan.
And literally we talked music,
we talked sports,
we talked everything
away from politics.
So by the time we actually did
get to some political issues,
we actually liked each other
and we could kind of
meet closer to empathy,
as opposed to just, like,
fisticuffs over the economy.
And we kind of thought, like,
maybe this is sort of
a unique way to approach
these "bipartisan"
conversations.
Like, start with culture,
start with things you love,
and then get to politics
in kind of an organic way.
-So, I mean,
I think that's great.
And I'm always so excited
when people from, you know,
differing political views talk.
But, of course, Governor Kasich
is an anti-Trump Republican.
Is there any --
Do you -- Does he feel like
there's any future of the party
for the lane
that he currently lives in?
-I mean, Governor Kasich
often talks about
feeling that the
Republican Party left him,
he didn't leave
the Republican Party.
And he's much more
of an optimist than I am
when we talk about the future.
I don't feel super great
about it.
I don't want to put words
in his mouth,
but I do think he is optimistic
that there are a lot
of moderates in this country
who are looking for people
to voice the concerns
that they have.
Actually I don't disagree
with him there.
But when I go to places
like CPAC,
what I'm seeing is --
I don't see those voices
being elevated.
I went to CPAC,
and I watched people
like Marjorie Taylor Greene
walk through there like Beyoncé.
And so she's got 10 people
behind her
with cameras taking pictures.
And there's a lot
of young conservatives
who are looking for attention,
and they see Boebert
and they see MTG,
and they're like, "That's how
you get attention nowadays."
And so, for me, I see the future
of the Republican Party,
the only lane seems to be
on the farther right
of Donald Trump.
I think Governor Kasich
might think it's somewhere else,
but I don't see any evidence
of it heading that way.
-You were at the insurrection,
January 6th.
You went back.
Are you surprised?
-As a member
of "The Daily Show."
-Yeah.
-It's not like I left something
inside the Capitol like,
"My wallet was in here.
It was in this lectern
when I flipped it over."
-You went back to try
to put back a laptop
you'd stolen
before you got caught?
-Yeah.
Legally,
I can't get too into it,
but I did go back to D.C., yes.
-Watching it --
I was watching it on TV.
I can't imagine
what it was like for you.
You thought like,
"Oh, this changes everything,"
and I don't know if it has.
-I don't think it has.
-Yeah.
-I think it did feel like a day
that could change everything.
I think we keep
having those days of,
"This is as far as we can go.
We all have to
get on the same page.
There's a common enemy,
and it's chaos.
If we could all rally around
this flag on this day."
And it felt like that lasted
for an hour or so
after the insurrection.
-Yeah. It was a nice hour.
-It was a good hour.
-It was a real nice hour.
I don't know.
I don't want to say I'm shocked,
because I'm not.
I think, like,
the news cycle moves so quick,
we don't have to have a memory
of those things.
And when I go
and talk to people --
I wouldn't talk to people
months after the insurrection.
And I was shocked how quick
that narrative changed.
And when I went back
a year later,
Matt Gaetz,
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
they're out there talking
about other narratives
that they want to push,
and so, sadly, I don't think
we remember the important things
from that day,
and that could bite us
in the ass.
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.
Thanks for getting out.
It's just fantastic.
Every time I see that
you've gone somewhere new,
I get very excited to watch it.
I really appreciate
you making time.
You guys, that's Jordan Klepper.
-Thank you.
-You can subscribe
to "Kasich & Klepper"
wherever you listen to podcasts.
And "Jordan Klepper
Fingers the Globe:
Hungary for Democracy"
premieres April 21st
on Comedy Central.